เฮ
[Música]
Boa noite, seja muito bem-vindos para
mais uma live dos apoiadores da
comunidade fechada.
É um prazer estar aqui com vocês.
Deixa eu colocar aqui o óculos que eu tô
esquecendo
e vamos responder as dúvidas. Não estou
em casa, não estou no consultório, como
vocês podem perceber.
Então eu quero que vocês me passam, por
favor, informação de como está o nosso
áudio de hoje, tá? Porque eu não estou
com o meu microfone externo que eu
habitualmente utilizo.
Então, para saber se o áudio tá OK, eu
preciso do feedback de vocês.
Vamos começar então.
Primeira pergunta, Dr. Alan. os remédios
que se colocam nas vacas que estão com
ferimento
popularmente conhecido como bicheira,
né, que seria miíase.
Essas toxinas passam para carne ou
leite? É perigoso consumir esse tipo de
carne? Qual alternativa saudável a isso,
já que animais se derem
e tem que curar? Aí a frase que tá um
pouquinho mal elaborada, né? Então,
esses remédios que são utilizados em
vacas com ferimentos, que nós chamamos
popularmente de bicheira, que é miíase.
Que que é mise? São as larvas das moscas
que ficam proliferando nas feridas.
Então, esse tipo de situação muito
frequente, né, no gado
e é necessário que se trate. E quais são
esses remédios? geralmente são
inteticidas das classes dos
organofosforados ou da classe das
avermectinas, né, cujo o principal
conhecido de vocês a ibermectina e tem a
abamectina também. Pode ser também
antibióticos tópicos e cicatrizantes que
vão ser utilizados para promover a cura
do tecido que tá infestado pela larva.
Então, esses produtos são necessários
porque a mi, né, em casos graves, pode
destruir rapidamente os tecidos,
principalmente os tecidos musculares do
animal e causar sofrimento severo ou
morte.
Então sim, esses remédios têm potencial
de deixar resíduo na carne e no leite se
não for respeitado um período chamado
período de carência, que é o tempo entre
o tratamento e o abate ou coleta do
leite. Então, existem estudos no Brasil
mostrando que leite e carne de animais
tratados contêm baixos níveis de resíduo
de medicamentos quando o período de
carência é respeitado,
ficando abaixo do limite considerado
seguro na legislação sanitária.
Porém, se for feito o uso incorreto, por
exemplo, aplicação em excesso ou abate
imediato após o tratamento, isso pode
levar a presença de resíduos acima do
recomendado.
Então, substâncias como abamectina ou
ivmectina, que eu não considero tóxicas,
né? Tô aqui repassando uma informação
que eu pesquisei a respeito desse
assunto.
Então, segundo esse texto, a abamectina
e a ivmectina não devem ser utilizadas
em vacas leiteiras durante a lactação.
E tá registrado que são frequentemente
detectadas em amostras desse gado
leiteiro.
Então, o consumo ocasional de carne ou
leite de animais tratados corretamente
não representaria um grande risco de
toxicidade imediata e o perigo potencial
maior estaria associado ao uso repetido
e indevido desses medicamentos que
poderia contribuir para a resistência
bacteriana, alergias em casos extremos,
intoxicação crônica a longo prazo.
Então, de modo geral, se for respeitado
o período de carência, essa carne é
considerada assim segura para consumo,
segundo os critérios da vigilância
sanitária.
No entanto, é sabido que pequenas
produções, né, pequenos produtores que
não são muito bem fiscalizados,
quando não há esse controle adequado,
existe sim um risco de carnes e leites
com resíduos de pesticidas
ou larvicidas, né, no caso as
ivimectinas ou até mesmo inteticidas.
Então, maior perigo estaria num consumo
acidental de dose acima do permitido,
mas pelo que eu pude apurar, isso é
raro.
Ou ainda o consumo constante,
que poderia favorecer reações adversas,
desenvolvimento de resistência
antimicrobiana
ou em casos pontuais, efeitos adversos
em pessoas sensíveis.
Então, existem sim alternativas para o
uso destes produtos, vem sendo
estudados, vem sendo adotados,
especialmente sistemas de criação
orgânicos. Então, existe hoje a gente
usando fitoterapia pro gado. Qual que
seria essa fitoterapia? Óleos
essenciais, com melaleuca, né, que é o
titri, o neem, a citronela.
São extratos de plantas como aloe vera
também. e calêndula, que teria efeito
antimicroombiano e cicatrizante,
poderiam ser utilizados localmente, né,
nas feridas do do gado, em casos leves,
amoderados e com menor risco de
resíduos. Então, já tem alguns
produtores usando esses óleos essenciais
ou aloe vera e calêndula para tratar
essas feridas.
E também tem alguns produtores
utilizando homeopatia,
que também não deixaria resíduos na
carne ou no leite.
Só que a gente não tem muitas
informações aí sobre a eficácia da
homeopatia
nesses casos. Aí
existe também medidas de controle
biológico e manejo, mantendo a higiene,
os ativos físicos, afastamento de áreas
de acúmulo de fees e uso de repelentes
naturais. Aí poderia utilizar os
repelentes de citronela, por exemplo,
para ajudar a evitar novas infestações
das moscas, né, que elas que vão
introduzir essas larvas a miíase.
E também estímulos à imunidade do animal
por meio de nutrição adequada,
suplementação com antioxidantes,
vitamina E, vitamina C, selênio, os
probióticos e zeitas.
Então tem alguns produtores a utilizando
também essas medidas.
Porém, nos casos graves, continua sendo
necessário o uso de medicamentos
convencionais
para poder garantir o bem-estar do
animal e também não permitir que ele
faleça por conta de meases graves.
Então, não vejo isso como um grande
problema, né? Esses resíduos tóxicos de
medicamentos contra a MAS e contra a
bicheira. não é tão comum.
Isso deve acontecer mais em produtores
pequenos que não respeitam os períodos
aí de carência.
Se você obter sua carne de produtores
seguros aí de carne proveniente de
animais tratados, respeitando o período
de carência, isso já minimiza muito esse
problema.
E já falamos sobre as alternativas
naturais.
Próxima pergunta, Orlistat, que é um
medicamento para emagrecer, que hoje já
não tá tão famoso, já não tá tão
utilizado, porque tem outras
alternativas aí mais modernas, né? Mas a
pergunta é sobre orlistate,
nome comercial xenical, e se ele poderia
causar desidratação
a ponto de causar uma isquemia cerebral
transitória. Então, a isquemia cerebral
transitória é um estado de baixa
circulação cerebral que antecede um AVC
isquêmico, né, um acidente vascular
cerebral isquêmico.
Teoricamente, oistate, como ele é um
medicamento que inibe absorção de
gordura,
ele pode então causar diarreia. de
geralmente essa diarreia não é muito
profusa e é um tipo de diarreia que nós
chamamos de esteatorreia, que é uma
diarreia onde prevalece gordura e também
pelo fato de sobrar gordura nas feeses,
isso leva a proliferação bacteriana, a
flatulência,
a fees oleosas e urgência fecal, porque
a pessoa tem dificuldade de segurar as
feeses quando está com esteatose do
tipo, quando está com esteatorreia, que
é a diarreia de gordura, tá? Então, não
há relatos assim diretos
em revisões ou diretrizes que associe
a deshidratação muito significativa que
poderia causar o AIT, né, ataque
isquêmico transitório.
Então, a gente não tem dados diretos
sobre isso. Agora, teoricamente, é
possível que isso aconteça se a pessoa
estiver muito desidratada,
porque a desidratação é um fator de
risco independente para eventos
isquêmicos cerebrais, pode aumentar a
viscosidade sanguínea e ativar a cascata
de trombose, a cascata de coagulação
trombogênica, né, potencializando assim
o risco de deterioração neurológica em
pacientes que já t risco aumentado para
a IT e para a VCI.
No entanto, a desidratação relevante a
ponto de induzir a IT, pelo menos eu não
achei relatos dizendo que o listate
sozinho foi capaz de induzir esse grau
de hidratação,
porque a desidratação tem que ser muito
relevante a ponto da pessoa realmente
chegar nesse ponto de ter o ataque
isquêmico. E geralmente ela decorre de
causas como vômitos intensos, diarreia
grave, perdas renais excessivas ou
condições clínicas severas. E isso não é
comum com a situação isolada do uso do
xenical do horlistat. Agora, se a pessoa
já tiver desidratada por outros motivos
e o horlistat aí foi o último prego no
caixão, pode ser realmente que ele tenha
sido o gatilho final aí para desenvolver
esse AIT.
Então, como é que a desidratação
precipitaria a isquemia cerebral
transitória? Através de alterações?
Através da redução do volume plasmático
circulante, do aumento da viscosidade
sanguínea, da hipoperfusão cerebral,
especialmente em áreas de circulação
limítrofe e o comprometimento do fluxo
em vasos já fechados, já estenosados.
Pessoal, tem alguém acompanhando ao
vivo? Porque eu estou sem feedback de
vocês.
Eu estou fora de casa. A internet daqui
não é tão estável quanto de casa, né?
Quanto do consultório. Então, pode ser
que vocês não estejam me ouvindo bem e
eu não estou tendo feedback. que ninguém
está se manifestando.
Deixa eu mandar uma mensagem no grupo
porque eu não tenho muita noção de como
é que tá a qualidade da transmissão. O
Antônio Renato acabou de se manifestar.
Boa noite, Antônio. Você me ouve, me
escuta bem?
Algum problema aí na transmissão? porque
eu não estou em casa. Luciano Delgado,
obrigado pela informação. Tá ouvindo
bem? Não tá tendo corte, né? Tá falhando
a transmissão para vocês. Me passem esse
feedback, por favor.
Segundo a Luciana, ela tá me escutando
bem, mas eu queria saber se a qualidade
da conexão tá adequada.
Então, voltando ao assunto da
desidratação
e do ataque químico transitório,
então como eu falei, a redução do volume
plasmático por conta da hidratação, o
aumento da viscosidade sanguínea
leva a hipoperfusão cerebral, isso vai
diminuir a circulação cerebral e o
comprometimento do fluxo em vaso,
especialmente que já estão estenosados.
Rouco. Eu não tô rouco não, mas tudo
bem.
Fatores de risco adicionais para o
ataque isquêmico transitório. Pacientes
que tença aterosclerótica prévia,
pessoas que têm já estenose carotídea,
né, a carótida fechada ou mesmo isso nos
vasos intracranianos.
Condição com anemia falsiforme, idosos
que têm mecanismos compensatórios
cuprometidos.
Então, ostart sozinho geralmente não é
associado à desidratação grave que pode
levar IT,
mas é teoricamente possível se a pessoa
tiver outros fatores de risco para
deshidratação, tá?
Uma
observação aqui, ostat, né, o xenical,
ele pode causar em pessoas que têm a
suscetibilidade, que são diabéticos ou
pacientes com uso prolongado do
medicamento e diarreia persistente,
uma desidratação severa e complicações
metabólicas,
tá? Mas a gente não tem assim um relato
direto em relação
a somente est utilizando ORL sem outros
fatores de risco ter essa associação com
ataque isquêmico transitório.
Eh, vamos pra próxima pergunta.
Doutor, para retirada de seis cálculos
renais, todos inferiores a 8 mm. Em
ambos oss, o procedimento mais indicado
é o heteterolitotsia
flexível
ou poderia ser atentado leco, que é
litripsia extracorpórea. Na tomografia
de abdômen, os cálculos parecem ser bem
densos, ainda sem laudo dos valores de
unidades Housefield. Se for
aureterolitotsia flexível, poderia-se
fazer o procedimento nos dois rins no
mesmo dia? Sim. Aí o ponto essencial é a
dureza dos cálculos, tá? Se esses
cálculos tiverem uma
dureza acima de 900 unidades housefield,
uma densidade alta, aí sim teria
indicação de fazer oreterpsia
com o laser. Então, cálculos densos,
geralmente a gente opta pela
oreterotsia,
oretero re nesse caso, porque os
cálculos estão no rim.
Agora, se for um cálculo na faixa de 800
unidades hofied ou
menos duro do que isso, aí pode tentar a
litripsia extracorpórea.
Então, falando em termos gerais, o a
Leco, né, que é a litra corpórea por
ondas de choque,
ela é indicada para cálculos geralmente
menores de 2 cm e com densidade abaixo
de 900 unidades Housefield.
e cálculos de alta densidade, como eu
comentei, entre, por exemplo, 1000 a
1200 unidades housefield vai responder
mal triplic extra corpórea, vai
necessitar de múltiplas sessões, isso
aumenta o risco de problema de pressão
alta a longo prazo e até de diabetes
e tem taxas crescentes de fragmentos
residuais.
Então aí nesses casos é indicado
oreterripsia
e hoje em dia já tem alguma segurança,
já tem experiência suficiente para fazer
esse procedimento bilateral, seja nos
dois rins ao mesmo tempo. Não haveria
problema nesse sentido.
Então, os cálculos mais duros e densos,
que é o caso do oxalato cálcio do tipo
monoidratado, a os cálculos de bruxita
ou de cistina, especialmente quando
múltiplos e bilateralmente distribuídos,
a dicação mais moderna é a uretero
renolitia.
E dá para fazer em ambos os insices
de resolução são próximos de 80 90% numa
única sessão.
As complicações são geralmente leves,
não tem um aumento substancial aí de
riscos quando tiver boa indicação em
centros com bastante experiência.
E é lógico que o tempo cirúrgico vai ser
maior quando o procedimento for
bilateral e pode haver necessidade de
duplo J no pós-operatório
até bilateral, que algumas pessoas é bem
comodativo.
Então, hoje em dia já é aceitável fazer
sim o renolitripsia
dos dois lados no mesmo ato e isso seria
bom porque reduziria o número de
anestesias, hospitalizações e custos e o
perfil de segurança considerado
aceitável.
As complicações mais comuns da orater
reno litripsia são leves, que é febre.
Eh, o desconforto do PLJ, algumas
pessoas sentem muito desconforto, muita
cólica, mas de modo geral é
relativamente bem aceito.
E obviamente vai depender tudo da
experiência do profissional que tá
realizando o procedimento. Se for um
médico muito experiente, dá
tranquilamente para fazer os dois lados
no mesmo procedimento,
tá? Então é isso. Se depois que você
tiver o exame na mão, confirmar que os
cálculos têm densidade acima de 900
unidades Housefield, aí tá indicado
fazer o reno, tá? Se for abaixo de 900
unidades, estaria aceitável fazer a
litia extracorpórea.
Próxima pergunta. Tem algo que ajude a
contrabalancear
os efeitos
do cloro na piscina?
Natação três vezes por semana tem feito
muito bem para mim, porém receio do
tratamento com cloro. Vou te passar umas
dicas aí. Boa noite, Rinaldo,
também está acompanhando aí a live ao
vivo. Vamos falar do cloro. Então, a
exposição frequente ao cloro pode causar
sim ressecamento na pele, ressecamento
nos cabelos, irritação nos olhos,
problemas respiratórios, especialmente
pessoas sensíveis.
por conta da formação das cloraminas,
que são os compostos formados quando
cloro reage com matéria orgânica, como é
o caso do suar e urina.
Esses compostos são tóxicos e isso
aumenta o estresse oxidativo no
organismo. Quais são estratégias então
para minimizar isso? Antes de nadar,
você faça uma ducha prévia com água
limpa para saturar a pele e cabelos com
água limpa antes de entrar na piscina.
Isso reduz de maneira significativa a
absorção do cloro. Então, os tecidos já
saturados com água limpa vão absorver
menos água colorada. Você pode aplicar
barreiras protetoras, isso se a pessoa
que administra a piscina não tiver
nenhuma ressalva, né?
Então você poderia aplicar óleo de coco
generosamente na pele e cabelos após a
ducha com água limpa antes do banho de
piscina
e o óleo formaria uma camada protetora
que reduziria o contato direto com o
cloro.
Você também poderia utilizar um produto
aí de proteção solar para cabelos que
chama live in. Esses produtos que não
tchaue eh formaria uma película
protetora nos fios.
e também cremes hidratantes espessos
paraa pele, poderia aplicar antes, que
são hidratantes à base de ceramidas e
lipossomos.
Novamente tem que ver se a administração
da piscina vai deixar você aplicar esses
produtos antes de entrar.
E outra coisa, você poderia utilizar
equipamentos de proteção, touca de
natação impermeável de silicone,
ajuda mais do que as de laicra e óculos
de natação bem vedados que vão proteger
os óleos e a córnea.
E outros procedimentos, neutralização
química do cloro pós uso da piscina.
você poderia estar utilizando a vitamina
C, o ácido ascóbico,
neutralizaria
o cloro para evitar a formação de
cloraminas.
Então você poderia utilizar a vitamina
C, tanto oral quanto tópica.
Poderia utilizar spray de vitamina C.
Não conheço isso, li a respeito, mas
geralmente
eu não conheço como é que utiliza esse
spray de vitamina C. Terei que tá
consultando uma farmacêutica de
manipulação, mas teoricamente seria 1 g
de vitamina C, 100 ml de água e dá o
spray na pele.
Me parece uma coisa simples, mas eu
nunca vi utilizar dessa maneira.
Tem algumas pessoas que poderiam ter
irritação na pele de aplicar essa
solução de vitamina C em água de maneira
direta, mas você poderia estar tomando
também 1 gama de vitamina C oral também,
né, e não utilizar diretamente na pele.
Nak também seria uma boa alternativa
neststeinaína,
porque aumentaria os níveis de
glutationa,
né? porque ele é o principal
precursor, né, limitante à formação da
gluta e protegeria então contra o
estresse oxidativo
sistêmico.
Além disso, NAC tem benefícios
adicionais paraa saúde respiratória,
ajudando detox hepático
e pessoas podem ter, infelizmente aí
alguns casos desconforto
gastrointestinal com NAC. Então tem que
observar especialmente em doses altas.
Pessoas que têm úlceras gástricas também
podem ter problema com os doc.
Então, já falamos cuidados antes de
entrar na piscina, cuidados
na piscina,
uso do NAC, da vitamina C. Agora vamos
falar dos cuidados pós natação. Tomar
uma ducha imediata para lavar o copo com
água morna, para retirar água colorada.
usar produtos de higiene específicos,
como sabonete neutro,
eh, para o corpo. Também tem um tipo de
sabonete especial sem sabão, que é o tal
de sindetes, que eu também não conheço.
Shampo antiresíduo
sem sulfato pros cabelos.
Então, você poderia estar tomando esse
banho logo após também o uso da piscina.
fazer também hidratação intensiva com
hidratantes corporais ricos em
ceramidas, ácido hialurônico e
antioxidantes
com a pele ainda úmida e usar também
máscaras capilares nutritivas pelo menos
uma vez por semana.
Água termal ao longo do dia poderia
ajudar a repor minerais na pele,
tá? Então, recapitulando aí o uso de
antioxidante. Vitamina C 1 g a 2 g ao
dia. Lembrando que você pode usar direto
na pele, como eu já comentei. A vitamina
E 400 unidades ao dia, o Nak de 600 a
1200 mg dia, o selênium por volta de 200
microg
e o esveratrol entre 250 a 500 mg ao
dia. E também sempre lembrando
de ter uma hidratação adequada.
Existem piscinas hoje que não usam mais
o cloro, né? Então, considerar a
possibilidade de utilizar aí uma piscina
sem cloro, se for viável para você.
Existe sistemas de piscinas que usam
ozônio,
que utilizam cloro reduzido. Existe
sistemas que usam sistemas salinos nas
piscinas
e existe a ionização com cobre e prata.
Então, todos esses métodos reduzem
bastante a utilização do cloro.
Tem uns truques também, tá? Eh, você
pode tentar tomar esse banho de piscina,
né, fazer essa natação de manhã cedo,
antes do horário que tem mais banhistas,
evitar o uso das piscinas após a
renovação da coloração, né, que é muitas
vezes acontece aí determinados dias do
mês
e preferir piscinas mais bem ventiladas
que vai reduzir concentração de
cloraminas no ar.
fazendo aí um resumo, tá? Um protocolo
sugerido, pré-natação 30 minutos antes,
tomar 1 g de vitamina Cural, tomar ducha
com água limpa, aplicar óleo de coco na
pele e aquele produto que não tem
enxagos.
Colocar touca de silicone e os óculos
protetores. Pós-natação, ducha com água
morna, lavar com sabonete neutro e
shampoo antiresíduos. Aplicar o spray de
vitamina C na pele, se você puder, é
opcional. hidratar pele e cabelo de
maneira adequada,
tá?
Próxima pergunta.
Dr. Alan, pesquisei no chat PT sobre
médicos que questionam sobre a morte
cerebral,
se seria um critério aceitável.
Encontrei nomes como Dr. Alan Sheumon.
Você ouviu falar dele? Não, antes de
você fazer a pergunta, não tinha ouvido
falar nele. Por favor, leia os
argumentos dele e de sua e dê a sua
opinião sobre os artigos desse autor aí.
Então, Dr. Alan Shelmon, é um professor
de neurologia pediátrica na CA, né, a
Universidade Católica de Los Angeles.
Ele é uma das vozes mais proeminentes e
controvérsias no questionamento dos
critérios de morte cerebral nas últimas
três décadas.
Então, o Dr. Chalm, ele apresenta
argumentos robustos, intelectualmente
robustos,
sobre o paradigma estabelecido de morte
cerebral, né? Porque qual é o paradigma
prevalente hoje em dia? Quando uma
pessoa
está muito enferma
e tem morte cerebral confirmada por
eletrocardiograma, eletrocefalograma,
perdão,
essa pessoa estaria clinicamente morta,
mesmo que os outros órgãos estejam
funcionando. E aí poderia se declarar a
morte dessa pessoa e até encaminhar os
órgãos para a doação.
Então ele questiona esse paradigma
estabelecido.
Porém, as conclusões dele não são ainda
totalmente aceitas e são controvérsias.
Então, os argumentos do Shelm, que faz
muito sentido,
que foi baseado especialmente em casos
extraordinários, não da rotina, né?
E aí vamos falar desses casos que ele
documentou de uma criança que sobreviveu
20 anos em ventilação mecânica. Isso é
muito raro, pessoal.
Então, essa criança sobreviveu 20 anos
em ventilação mecânica após diagnóstico
de morte cerebral por menengite
bacteriana. Mas que qualidade de vida é
essa, né?
20 anos em ventilação mecânica.
Eu não não considero isso vida, tá?
Minha opinião pessoal já não é opinião
médica.
Ficar 20 anos aí agonizando um
ventilador, para mim isso não é vida.
Então teve o caso também do Jarri McM
sobreviveu quase 5 anos. após declaração
de morte cerebral,
inclusive apresentando menarca, ou seja,
era uma menina que era uma criança que
acabou tendo aí essa primeira
menstruação
eh depois da morte cerebral. De novo,
será que isso é vida? Ficar vegetando
num ventilador?
Aí eu coloco a pergunta para vocês.
Múltiplos casos de gestantes com morte
cerebral que levaram gestações a termo.
Tá aí um outro argumento se valeria a
pena manter a pessoa viva por conta do
bebê. Aí eu sou totalmente a favor, né,
para você preservar a vida do bebê.
Agora, os outros casos aí que a pessoa
teoricamente não morreu, né? tá só com
morte cerebral, mas não teve
deteorização dos outros órgãos. Aí é bem
discutível.
Então, contrariando o paradigma
tradicional, se Dr. Shelmon demonstrou
que o corpo mantém funções integradas
significativas sem o cérebro,
que ele continuaria tendo cicatrização
de feridas,
que aconteceria
combate a infecções, crescimento
proporcional em crianças, maturação
sexual, como eu foi falado da menina que
chegou a ter a menarca, né, a primeira
menstruação, regulação hormonal parcial,
já que a função hipotalâmica e
pituitária estariam preservadas, apesar
da função cortical aí mais
elevada não tá funcionando e também
estariam preservando homeostase
cardiovascular.
Então, Dr. Shelmon argumenta de maneira
convincente que o cérebro não é o órgão
exclusivamente necessário para
integração orgânica e que a vida
emergeria da interação entre todos os
tecidos, não só de um comando central
único.
E ele documenta casos de preservação
prolongada de função neuroendócrina e
até atividade elétrica residual em
pacientes declarados com morte cerebral.
Então estaria questionando a
irreversibilidade, apesar de que eu não
tô vendo nenhum caso aqui que de fato a
pessoa acordou, digamos assim, depois de
uma suposta morte cerebral. Então são
pessoas que ficaram muitos anos vivendo
de maneira vegetativa
e não recuperaram a consciência, tá?
Mesmo com esses argumentos aí
interessantes desse doutor.
Então, o Dr. Shelmon apresenta
evidências empíricas robustas que
desafiam a coerência filosófica do
conceito de morte cerebral e do ponto de
vista conservador e bioético, os seus
argumentos ressouvam com princípios
fundamentais sobre a sacralidade da vida
humana.
Esses casos documentados demonstrariam
de forma inequívoca que o diagnóstico de
morte cerebral não corresponderia a
cessação completa da integração
orgânica. Então, se aceitarmos que a
morte é a desintegração reversível do
organismo como um todo, então esses
pacientes claramente não estariam mortos
no sentido biológico tradicional. Então
eu acho que os argumentos dele fazem
muito sentido. Só que de novo, para que
que você vai viver 5 a 20 anos desse
jeito? Não vejo sentido, tá? De novo,
sou eu que tô decidindo se vai desligar
o aparelho. Não sou eu. Eu só tô
questionando a para que que serve esse
tipo de vida, né?
A evolução das posições do próprio
Shelmon são notáveis porque no passado
ele defendia
que o critério neocortical, ou seja,
falta de atividade no córtex cerebral,
já seria um critério suficiente de
morte. Isso ele defendia nos anos 80,
tá? 1980.
Mas aí com o tempo ele foi mudando a
opinião dele com os estudos, né? ele
revisou completamente a posição inicial
dele, que ele concordava com o conceito
de morte cerebral.
Então, do ponto de vista médico legal e
ético, as implicações são profundas,
porque a persistência de funções
integradas
iria sugerir que estamos lidando com
pacientes gravemente lesionados, mas não
cadáveres. E isso levantaria questões
éticas sérias sobre o transplante de
órgãos e suspensão de esporte vital.
Então, a comunidade científica médica
tem sido muito defensiva nesse ponto,
não tem aceitado os argumentos desse Dr.
Shelman
e tentam preservar o status qu
através de redefinições conceituais cada
vez mais abstratas, como a proposta de
da organização Presidence Council on
Bioethics de 2008.
Então assim, a minha conclusão final,
os argumentos de Shelmon são
cientificamente sólidos, são eticamente
importantes,
eles nos forçam a confrontar a realidade
que o conceito de morte cerebral foi
originalmente proposto por conveniência
prática e não através assim de uma
certeza absoluta de que a pessoa
realmente não estaria mais aqui e nem
por coerência filosófica. Então, eu não
tenho uma resposta definitiva quanto a
isso. O que eu posso dizer a vocês que
eu não gostaria de viver dessa maneira
vegetativa
eh através de aparelhos seria uma
perspectiva de poder voltar a ficar
consciente, tá?
Aí temos aqui uma intervenção do Antônio
Renato. Mas o doutor, o senhor diz que
não é vida, mas se a família quer
manter, pode ser que um dia durante essa
manutenção dos aparelhos pode surgir uma
cura. Nunca surgiu, Antônio Renato.
Nunca uma pessoa que chegou nesse ponto
voltou atrás, que eu saiba, tá?
Talvez algumas pessoas com alguns anos
voltem ao normal. Eu acho muito, muito
improvável. Tá? E a gente não tem como
saber como é que tá sendo o sofrimento
dessa pessoa. Esse que é o ponto, tá?
Mas de novo, são opiniões. A sua opinião
é tão boa quanto a minha, viu?
Não tenho nenhuma pretensão aqui de
colocar a minha opinião prevalescente
sobre a sua. Eu acho que é um assunto
muito difícil de concluir qualquer coisa
a respeito, tá? Eu só digo a vocês que
para mim, se eu tiver numa situação
dessa, só vivo através de uma máquina e
sem atividade cortical, eu prefiro
deixar esse plano de existência. Essa é
a minha opinião. Agora, eu não tenho a
menor pretensão de decidir isso sobre a
vida de pessoas
alheias, né? E espero que eu nunca tenha
que decidir isso para nenhum membro da
minha família.
Hoje parece que tudo é para tirar os
órgãos. No Brasil parece que não há
alternativa. Aí é um outro problema,
Antônio. Entendo o seu posicionamento.
Vamos pra próxima pergunta.
Gente, tem uma pergunta aqui, eu vou
responder ela em modo geral, mas eu peço
para vocês tomarem muito cuidado na hora
de elaborar as perguntas, porque eu já
falei isso várias vezes aqui, mas a
gente pode ter membros novos que não
estão sabendo, apesar de que tá isso
explicado, né, no texto lá do grupo do
WhatsApp,
tem pessoas que formulam algumas
perguntas que são extremamente
específicas para um problema pontual
de saúde da própria e que tem
praticamente ente valor muito baixo para
o grupo em si e acaba sendo uma
tentativa de consulta, né, sem passar em
avaliação específica, né? Então, por
respeito essa pessoa, eu não vou
identificar quem que fez a pergunta, mas
é uma pergunta extremamente elaborada
aqui, convoluta, difícil até de
responder, mas eu vou fazer meu melhor e
para responder de modo geral, mas que a
maioria das pessoas não vão ter muito
interesse nesse assunto, tá?
Então é sobrecisteína,
é uma pessoa que tem dificuldade de
manterína sob controle e essa pessoa
especificamente tem
um bom funcionamento renal, tá
utilizando a maioria dos suplementos que
baixamína, que é o nac, trimetioglicina,
que é a betaína base, metiofolato,
meticombolamina, porém tem dificuldade
de baixar os valores de homocisteína
e ela teria um sonho
de que o ciclo de metilação dela
funcionaria bem e que no final teria uma
boa polução de gluta ela tem também um
problema no gene que codifica
a gluta
deleção de algum desses genes da gluta
não especifica qual que é uma deleção aí
e também tem uma outro problema genético
que é um problema de sulfatação.
Ele tem um snip, né, um polimorfismo, um
gene chamado suti 1 a1 com a troca aí do
A pelo G.
e tem uma baixa detoxificação.
E por conta disso tem um acúmulo de
glicosaminoglicanos, né, que é a sigla
Gag,
tá? E tem um diagnóstico de uma doença
de base MPS2 e 3.
Então é uma coisa extremamente
específica problema de saúde aqui, tá?
Então vou falar aqui rapidamente sobre
isso porque é uma pergunta que é muito
específica e não interessa o grupo como
um todo.
Tem também um problema de uma enzima que
quebra a hidruronato dois sulfatase que
tem disfunção nessa enzima, tá? Então
vamos lá, né? Que que faz baixar a
homocisteína?
Antes de falar da homoina, tem mais uma
observação aqui. Existe um remédio para
diminuir o glucos aminoglicanos, que ele
tem acúmulo dessas moléculas, que é o
tal do alfa vestrina, não conheço, tá?
Alfa vestronidase.
Ele tá comentando aqui que é muito caro,
não tem condições de comprar.
Ele quer que eu ajudaria ele a montar
uma estratégia para evitar o acúmulo
das glicos aminoglicanas e os
nutraceutos que poderia utilizar. O
pessoal do grupo orientou que poderia
utilizar genisteína, fizetina,
espermidina.
Então vamos lá.
O que que pode ajudar aí? Vou falar de
uma maneira geral
pras pessoas que estão acompanhando aí a
live para baixar esse marcador sistema.
que é um marcador de inflamação
e o marcador de metilação.
Coisas que ele já tá utilizando que são
os folatos e vitamina B12, metiofolato,
metilcobalamina.
Nós sabemos que a conversão de
homocisteína e meteonina, que nós
queremos baixar a homocisteína, então
convertendo em meionina depende
da B9 e da B12 e a cuplementação reduz a
moscitina sanguínea.
A vitamina B6 ajuda também porque ele
participa na transforação da
homocisteína pra cistationina,
só que não deve ser utilizado
isoladamente. Então você deve utilizar
B2, B6, B9, B12.
Então a B2 é um cofator da metilena
tetaridofolato redutasa, que é enzima
que converte o ácido fólico metfolato.
Então vai ajudar também, né, em pessoas
que tm uma cistína elevada. Então, B2,
B6, B9, B12,
tá? Basicamente esses são os mais
importantes para baixar a homocisteína.
Também a betaína, tá? Que é um doador de
metil, porque é a trimetil glicina, são
três moléculas de metil para uma
glicina. E a glicina também faz parte da
formação
da gluta junto com
e o ácido glutâmico. Então a
trimetiloglicina também vai ajudar
doando grupos metil e permitindo que a
betaína homocisteína metiltransferase,
que é uma enzima, que ela converta a
homisteína em metionina
até 50% da remetilação hepática
realizada por essa enzima. Então tem
estudos controlados mostrando que uso de
até 4 a 6 g por dia. Não sei que dose
essa pessoa tá utilizando, mas você pode
usar doses alta de trimetiloglicina, tá?
Caso você esteja usando doses baixas,
pode aumentar a dose para ver se isso
resolve ajudar a baixar a cisteína.
Doses muito altas de trimetoglicina
podem às vezes aumentar o colesterol
IDL, tá?
O zinco também é um cofator
de enzimas remetiladoras
e você pode
utilizar em tom de 30, 50
mgudarativamente.
bidênium, coisa também que geralmente eu
não utiliz
ele integra uma coenzima de quatro
enzimas chamado
sulfitoxidase. Então, o molbidênio
catalisa a conversão de sulfito em
sulfato, que é uma etapa necessária para
o metabolismo cisteína e meteonina.
Então, poderia ser também uma estratégia
para baixar a homocisteína.
Então, mole bidum também uma é uma dica
aqui para abaixar octina.
E dicas de dieta e estilo de vida.
reduzir o consumo de café, porque o
consumo exagerado de café pode aumentar
sistémina acima de quatro xícaras por
dia. Moderar o consumo da carne
vermelha, que é fonte do aminoácido
meteonina, que pode virar cisteína,
reduzir o consumo de álcool, aumentar o
consumo de vegetais crucíferos e de alho
que podem fornecer enxofre e ativar a
via NRF2.
Ele falou que tem problema com a
sulfatação, então o consumo de vetais
crucíficos pode tá utilizando.
Exercício regular também e manutenção do
peso adequado vão ajudar a reduzir a
inflamação, tá? Essa pessoa que tem
sulfatação comprometida
tem uma redução drástica da atividade
enzimática pelo polimorfismo
do genul 1 a1.
Então, nesses casos, a gente sugere
o suporte de enxofre, como eu comentei,
utilização de alimentos que t enxofre,
como é o caso dos do gênero alho, né,
que é o alho e a cebola. e também
peixes,
ovos, brócolis, covlor,
leguminosas e alguns grãos que vão
ajudar a fornecer enxofre. Então, comer
mais alimentos com enxofre para ajudar
nessas enzimas aí que dependem do
enxofre, que é sufransferases,
tá?
O banho também com sal deon que é o
sulfato de magnésio, ajuda bastante
porque a pessoa absorve o sulfato pela
pele e também a suplementação com SMM
para reastecer o pulo de sulfato.
Já comentamos sobre o molidênio, também
ajuda na conversão de sulfito em sulfato
pelo uso da enzima sulfitoxidase.
também pode ajudar
nesses casos que a sulfatação
está prejudicada
e evitar inibidores da sufatação, que é
o caso dos flavonoides em consumo
excessivo. Quer dizer, mesmo a quecetina
sendo ótimo antiflamatório natural, se
você consumir demais ele, ele pode
inibir inibir, né, a as sufatases.
Então, nesse caso, não estaria indicado
uso excessivo de quecetina, nem de
curcumina, nem de resveratrol.
A cafeína também pode induzir, tá, eh,
esses problemas de sulfatação, mas em
doses elevadas.
Então, estratégias também para reduzir o
acúmulo das glucamin glucosaminoglicanos
e modular a MPS, né? Usar, como ele até
mesmo comentou, inibidores da síntese de
glutaminoglicose,
que é os gags, né?
que é a genína, é um deles. O outro é
uma medicação que ainda não foi liber
que é o diparcil,
que é um estilo sintético que desvia a
síntese de das glucosaminoglicanos
para espécies solúveis
e reduzindo o acúmulo intracelular
através do aumento de excreção na urina.
E tem também, como ele mesmo comentou, a
fizetina e a espermidina,
que vão modular autofagia, inflamação.
Isso vai ajudar a favorecer a degradação
das glucosas aminoglicanas.
Tem estudos em modelos de animais que a
fizetina inibe a emitor e isso favorece
a degradação dessas glucosaminoglicanas,
tá?
E o mesmo reseratrol que eu já comentei
agora a pouco que poderia em excesso
causar problemas, né, porque seria um
inibidor aí da sulfatação,
ele em quantidades menores pode ali
ajudar a eliminar o excesso de glucoso
aminoglicanos, tá? Então isso é uma
coisa meio
estranha, né? é meio paradoxal, mas sim
poderia utilizar o respiratório em
baixas dosagens para ajudar a reduzir o
acúmulo dos glicosaminoglicanos.
Uso da comenzima Q10 também seria uma
boa, uma faixa de 100 a 200 mg por dia.
E também existe aí algumas drogas, como
é o caso do pentosano, polissulfato,
mas ela tem alta toxicidade e o
antidepressivo floxetina, que poderia
ajudar a reduzir o acúmulo dos gagues
pro aumento de síntese glutationa, além
da trimetiloglicina
e da nectocisteína, seria interessante
também usar a glutationa sublingual ou a
glutationa lipossômica, que seria seria
o antioxidante de forma direta.
Também ajudaria a utilizar a taurina,
que são aminoácidos sulfurados que podem
melhorar a conjugação de bil e apoiar a
transsufração.
E a própria trimetiloglicina com
aminoácido glicina participa no ciclo da
sarcosina e no balanço entre o SAM, né,
o adenosil homocisteína e o adenosilina.
Tá, eu tô falando grego pra maioria de
vocês, mas tô tentando responder a
pergunta da pessoa, tá?
Então, recapitulando, ajustar as doses
de B9, B12, B2, B6, trimetoglicina,
talvez aumentar a doseoglicina seja o
ponto principal aqui. E o zinco,
aumentar o consumo de alimentos inclus
enxofre e molibidênio, fazer os banhos
de sal de épson.
Eh, considerar o uso da genisteína e da
espermidina e da fisetina e resveratrol
em baixas dosagens. E a cor em cima que
é 10 nessa faixa aí de 100 a 200 mg por
dia e o NAC até 1200 mg por dia. Tá?
Próxima
pergunta.
Mas antes deixa eu ver aqui as
observações aqui.
Maria Helena tá fazendo a observação
com 700 de B12. Não tá baixa essa B12
não, viu?
Um adulto pode tomar quantas
miticobalamina injetável? Não precisa
aumentar mais do que isso.
Já tá bom.
Aí a Ana Paula
se manifestando sobre isso, né?
Aqui a dica do Paula Resveratrol
Resvitec
que seria uma de absorção melhor.
Bem, vamos pra próxima pergunta aqui.
Doutor, ainda relativa a cálculos
renais, líquido ideal é manter o pH da
urina em 6,5, entre 6 e 7, pois essa
faixa de pH
dificulta a famação de novos cristais de
oxalato e cálcio. Eu poderia utilizar um
pH, um pH, né, um medidor de pH na urina
e suplementos com bicarbonato de sódio,
se trato de potássio
e ou se trato de magnésio para regular o
pH da urina.
Sim, estudos de 2024 confirmam que
manter o pH da urina entre 6 e 7 é uma
estratégia eficaz para prevenir a
formação de cálculos de oxalato de
cálcio.
Pesquisas recentes demonstraram que
cristais de oxalato de cálcio
monoidratado,
eles cristalizam-se
em maior quantidade num pH ácido
e a formação deles é mínima em pH mais
próximo da alcalina.
Então, monitorar o pH urinário é uma
prática interessante, útil e viável.
E se for viável, é bom realizar medições
múltiplas ao longo do dia, especialmente
nas primeiras urinas da manhã e após as
refeições, para obter um perfil completo
das variações de pH. Então temos que
manter nessa faixa que você comentou
entre 6 e e 7,
evitando valores abaixo 5,5, que poderia
favorecer a formação de cálculo de ácido
úrico e também evitar que fique acima de
sete, que pode promover a forma ação de
cálculo de fosfato de cálcio.
E eu utilizo de rotina meus pacientes
que t facilidade com uma pedra uma
combinação de citrato de potássio e
citrato de magnésio junto com
quebra-pedra.
As vantagens de citrato de potássio, ele
é considerado um padrão ouro
para manter a alcalinização urinária.
Ele aumentaria a excreção de citrato
urinário, que é um potente inibidor de
fumação de pedras de cristalização e
reduziria a excreção do cálcio urinário.
A dose que se recomenda
é de 20.000 família equivalentes duas a
três vezes ao dia e tem uma eficácia
comprovada de redução de 75%
na recorrência de cálculos em estudos
atomizados. Porém, o se trato de
potássio pode causar problemas
gastestinais
em 30 a 48% dos pacientes. Pessoas que
têm sufia renal ou usam diuréticos
poupadores de potássio não poderia
utilizar.
teria que monitorar o potássio do
sangue, pode aumentar em alguns casos.
E nesse caso, por isso que eu utilizo em
conjunto com o extrato de magnésio, que
tem as vantagens de ser disponível
sem prescrição e mais acessível de forma
econômica, mais barato.
Terator de fornecer o magnésio, que é
outro inibidor de fumação de pedras, que
tem vários outros achados positivos pra
saúde humana. Teria um efeito lacante
que poderia ser benéfico para algumas
pessoas.
E a dose então do magnésio típica é de
400 mg do magnésio elementar ao dia na
forma de se trata de magnésio.
Então o ideal na minha opinião, é fazer
a associação de citrato de magnésio com
citrato de potássio.
Qual seria a desvantagem se trato de
magnésio? Poderia ser ruim um efeito
laxante para algumas pessoas.
E poderia ser necessário também doses
múltiplas diárias para manter o pH
adequado.
O bicarbonato é uma opção interessante
por ser barato e ser muito disponível.
A dose típica do bicarbonato é de 650 mg
quatro vezes ao dia, que vão fornecer 30
m equivalentes de álcale. E é uma
alternativa interessante quando o
citrato
de potássio não é tolerado.
A desvantagem do bicarbonato que apesar
dele alcalinizar a urina, ele não
aumenta o citrato na urina, que por si
só inibe a formação de pedras de forma
direta.
ou a carga de sódio do bicarbonato pode
ser significativa
e pode aumentar calciúura, ou seja, a
eliminação de cálcio na urina.
O bicarbonato pode causar distensão
abdominal e não é recomendado em
pacientes com pressão alta ou
insuficiência cardíaca.
Então eu sugeriria fazer o uso conjunto
de citrato de potássio e magnésio
e ele é mais eficaz do que o uso do
citrato de potássio ou do citrato de
magnésio de forma isolada. E a
combinação então forneceria dois
inibidores de cristalização
simultaneamente.
E é importantíssimo também mantenha uma
hidratação adequada
paraa pessoa eliminar mais de 2,5 L de
urina por dia.
Bem, pessoal, essa é foi a última
pergunta. Foram perguntas aí
intensas hoje, né? Então, eu tinha o
texto separado aqui para discussão de
artigos, mas eu vou deixar paraa semana
que vem, tá? Vamos ver aqui
os comentários da Ana Paula
sobre Coenzema Q10. Qual a sua opinião
sobre o Cavac? Eu utilizo esse produto,
mas eu não tenho muita certeza se ele é
superior a com enzima que é 10
convencional, para te falar a verdade,
isso aqui foi um comentário dela falando
que o Resc é é uma boa marca deatrol.
Ela explicando aqui que os diuréticos
poupadores de potássio são da classe da
cortaridona hidroclorazida.
Não, na verdade o hidroclorazida não é
por de potássio não, né?
Seria o espiron lactona, que é o o
diurético pador de potássio.
Ah, uso de PC fosfatodinositol
seria indicado para evitar a formação de
novos cálculos. Já uso 1500 mg de
citrato de magnésio por dia e mesmo
assim desenvolvi novos cálculos.
Você tá usando só o citr de magnésio,
eu sugeriria você utilizar citrato de
magnésio, citrato de potássio e
quebra-pedra junto, que é o que eu passo
pros pacientes, tá? E sim, o exafosfato
deusitol poderia ajudar, mas não seria
um agente principal para isso não, viu,
Fernando?
Bem, pessoal, nós estamos aí já com uma
hora de live. Eu vou encerrar por aqui,
tá? A não ser que tenha mais uma
pergunta. Vou esperar aí um pouquinho
mais, esperar aí mais uns 2 minutos. Ah,
mas tem mais perguntas aqui.
Vou introduzir os dos dois citratos. De
nada, Fernando.
Isso é importante, viu, Fernando, essa
observação do Torna Paulo para fazer
análise dos cálculos urinários.
Quebra pedra, chal cápsulas. Eu faria
manipulado citrato de potássio, citrato
de magnésio junto com quebrapedra em pó,
tudo junto, tá?
Obrigado, Maria Helena. Um abraço para
você.
Boa noite.
De nada, Fernando. Abraço para você
também. Pessoal, então muito obrigado
pela presença de vocês. Quem não
assistiu ao vivo sabe, né, que sempre
fica gravado. Então, avisem lá no grupo
para quem não sabe, tá, que todas as
lives ficam gravadas e disponíveis
eternamente quando a pessoa fizer parte
do grupo de apoiadores, tá? Formulário.
Então, só se você colocou agora. Parece
que tem mais perguntas assim que eu não
tinha visto. É, foram agora que
colocadas aqui. Doutor Alan, na sua
visão, autismo moderado leve tem
remissão? O leve sim, o moderado, eu
acho que não tem remissão, tem bom
controle, tá?
Eh, eu acho que autismo leve é possível
remissão, sim. Eu já falei isso em lives
anteriores. Se vocês verem os vídeos
anteriores, eu comentei em dois vídeos
anteriores sobre esse assunto.
Por que que é tão complicado a
regeneração do cérebro com morte
cerebral? Porque o tecido neuronal é de
dificíimo regeneração. É basicamente
essa a resposta pra pergunta.
Quais as possíveis pesquisas? Aí não é
questão de pesquisa, tá?
É uma questão de que ninguém que teve
morte cerebral declarada conseguiu
voltar a ter consciência. É isso que eu
tava querendo dizer. Não sei se ficou
claro. Isso não é uma questão de
pesquisa, é uma questão de observação do
dia a dia de pessoas que sofreram esse
diagnóstico aí de morte cerebral, tá
bom? Então não é que tem uma pesquisa
necessária,
é a mesma coisa você falar para mim.
Quais são as pesquisas que provam que
pular do avião sem para-quedas a pessoa
morre ou a pessoa sofre uma queda fatal?
Não precisa de pesquisa porque é um fato
comprovado empiricamente, tá? Então,
todo mundo que teve morte cerebral
confirmada não conseguiu voltar a ter
consciência. Esse que é o ponto, tá?
Agora, eu não tô discutindo aqui a
ética, tá? Eh, a ética de manter as
pessoas vivas ou não é outra história.
Eu tô dizendo que eu particularmente
nãoi de viver hoje de uma morte
cerebral, mesmo que eu seja considerado
ainda vivo, porque meus sistemas
orgânicos estão funcionando, tá? Ah, mas
talvez daqui a 10 anos vai descobrir um
jeito de reverter. Eu acho que 10 anos é
um prazo muito curto para isso e mesmo
assim é raríssimo, é raríssimo casos que
passam anos aí com morte cerebral e que
os órgãos continuam funcionando aí por
vários anos que eu tô dizendo, não
poucas semanas, tá?
É isso que eu tô querendo dizer. Espero
que vocês tenham entendido.
Ã, abraço para todos vocês. Antônio
Renato também, ao Reginaldo,
[Música]
ao Fernando, ao Rinaldo,
ao Fernando Casteli
a Maria Helena.
Obrigado aí por vocês terem participado
ao vivo. Até a próxima, pessoal. Ciao.
Ciao.